and let's play risa lion from position
that this is Ivan like don't want to
lose in a while but this is always
unsettling because I have no idea what
position we're about to see ooh
regards okay interesting
that's probably leveling the playing
field
oh I can't Castle kingside that's so sad
well opening to play hmm oh this is
actually interesting and I have to
choose an opening where this rook won't
be so important a budapest probably
makes no sense
maybe Kings Indian yeah like g6 or maybe
a hippo ooh
opponent playing London okay so well a
good thing about how not having a rook
on h8 is that I can't lose a rook you
can't lose something you don't have it
also kind of creates a nice pocket of
air so like Heaney has a nice of safe
play area even though I can't castle
okay so I'm kind of just completing the
Kings Indian setup I'm realizing I'm not
gonna have work yet to prepare a 5 so
it's a question of how to get this move
in maybe the other work has to come into
play
why playing very solidly playing the
quintessential London setup but the
setup is least with a bishop on d3 it's
not so great against the structure does
this just win a piece those wins apiece
let's go
yeah so rather than having a rock on ye
I have my queen on you and the problem
for white is I'm a threatening a bishop
I'm also a threatening a fork not so
easy to stop Jacob Marshall yeah
soon to be early morning but thanks for
the bits yeah so this is actually a very
common sort of tactical idea and
especially against the London that's
usually why the bishop should be on e 2
and not T 3 thanks so much but I'm still
down material like it even after I win
with a minor piece I'm still gonna be
down the exchange and probably a pawn
that's the problem with being dollar
rook like you win a Myra piece and
you're still down material Oh to do yeah
there is some idea of why playing this
and E 4 and then takes but then I just
take back so ok might as well win
something
realizing C 7 is also going to fall yeah
I mean I support is appreciated if I put
this on youtube
sometimes a YouTube people get annoyed
but as long as I understand it's all in
good fun
thanks again my my name is Prem oh my
name is Prem Attila that's an exotic
name who names are their child Prem does
that stand for something maybe it stands
for something
das although with more gifted subs I'll
probably I'll probably put this on
youtube
I'm envisioning a YouTube video that's
called something like Records
and it's gonna be interesting like this
game is still not not in my favor the
thing we're kind of simplifying to like
I have one material that we traded and
trade it off a lot of pieces but what do
I have I have two bishops opponent wants
a queen trade this is a really annoying
move because like I don't want to take
even though I probably have to take I
could play queen here but then my Lucy
seven maybe Queen may be queen e8
it's a sad move though at least I keep
Queens on the board yeah thanks so much
das auto
gifting Suggs to the real Matt Damon me
haha oh oh well thanks for the prem
thanks for the love yeah good move maybe
this move i'll queen d8 it's hard to
stop though yeah just go for this I'll
have to bishops I guess I already have
two bishops light spread Bishop maybe
could be a nice weapon I'll try and
confuse my opponent visibie six Grammys
pronounced prayin prayin prey and uh huh
yeah pardon my pronunciation yeah so the
the Queen basically defends a rook
through x-ray vision but everything's
kind of safe but yeah White has AI has a
rook into pollens for a bishop but I
have more time
okay so sadly the Queen Queen goes away
I think nine takes is probably best cuz
I attacked the bishop and threatening
the pawn on c4 I'm also turning the plan
B - so I'm going back upon but we are
trading more things hmm
or are we maybe f6 f6 is probably the
way to go it it's really sad for this
Bishop but at least it keeps things on
the board kicks away this bishop I'll
win the pawn and get tempo on the rook
it's gonna be a fight
what to do 41 so white wants to play
rook d7 I probably still have to play
like somewhat restrictive Lee I think
Bishop e6 might be a go-to move even
like putting the bishop on c6 yeah but
it made sense sometimes sometimes you
have to always play off six if that
makes any sense
oh like kicking around my bishop this
would be a very brave move I'm wondering
if I can get away with this there's also
a bit about seven White's playing very
smartly I just trying to keep things
controlled and trade hmm this bishop is
it's so valuable because white doesn't
have a light squared bishop I completed
this and juice f3 I probably only helps
white I played this it's too it trying
to confuse my opponents yeah I think so
everyone for the bits if you ain't first
you look here last I'm gonna try and
finish above last place in this game so
basically like my bishops undefended
aligned with the rook but wherever the
knight moves forward I just take the
knight with the bishop so okay h3 each
three is just a nothing move but
basically asking me what I'm doing here
because I don't know what I'm doing
maybe this move
[Music]
90 sudden that they wants to activate
yeah probably in 87 then King he eats
just to defend the bishop I played our
man Hambleton yesterday and on move
seven I started sweating because I was
so nervous first time I've played a GM
yeah it can be nerve-racking but usually
you just have to take a deep breath and
don't sweat too much to do a four I
meant stupid no flu yeah also maybe dumb
or maybe here okay let's let's focus
let's focus let's be positive that's why
King he ate two to hold on to the Bishop
white wanted to play this move which is
kind of no longer great cuz when I can
just take twice yeah we're both getting
kind of low on time but White's getting
more long time there's a five second
increment but time might be my my saving
grace here we'll see oh I finally
realized Prem Prem is short for pre-move
you can't spell pre-move without pram
which means love hmm maybe that's a sign
I should start pre moving eventually f4
f4 is something
wondering if I can play this move I feel
like I'm slowly being squeezed like
whites grabbing grabbing control all
areas of the board and now I don't know
what to do some random a6 I have this
move
maybe this move I have five like it's if
I played out of five or if I allow a
night at five then white forces all
these trades
maybe rook t8 idea to play Knight here
and then it's my the five I can just
take it and defend
hmm I'm trying to be like very patient
and just waiting like waiting for my
opportunity or just waiting for white
splendor but I mean after giving the
away material in the opening whites it's
playing a very decent game I'm not sure
if I want to take just trying to apply
pressure light would be very happy on e4
hard to get there though if I take b6 a
six sort of b6 just dreaming of like a
bishop getting here and then doing
tactics yeah it's not even that great
though or is it maybe it is let's try it
aligning with the king
yeah I probably wasn't so great yeah I
could move oh this is tough yeah I just
allowed me four is very strong he
four-fifths facilitates so many trades
if I play a six it could be a tricky
move the promise takes that just doesn't
work if I take this way I might be the
best try like takes takes takes and some
a five move not what I want but let's go
for it so my whole idea is f5 hoping for
for some miracle hoping that the two
bishops can can really prove some some
power in this position but it kind of
came at the cost of trading from trading
pretty much everything I like Kiki eight
I just want to find a safe square for my
king
if I wasn't down material that I would
love to take and take but I don't really
want to trade off this bishop but maybe
white doesn't know that whoo whoo I'll
such a nice gift that's what I was
waiting for her it was like one one slip
of the mouse and one like this bad move
and yeah now I take here and now the two
bishops two bishops are are thriving
still takes a little bit of effort rook
see Simon coming okay let's uh yeah
prevent the rook from from infiltrating
if before I have this move
are we gonna see reg aids Bishop's move
backwards okay white being safe that was
grab of hon yeah this is a very solid
formation this is a fork so that turned
around kind of quickly at least some
combination of time pressure and plus
the bishop hair
I always play off 3do I'm joy mica third
bishop for the showboating I make three
bishops I started the game down at rook
it's like I earned the right to showboat
right how am i under promotes as a
control altar shift Oh that draws an
arrow let's try this
there we go there's a trick on me chess
because I have Auto Queen set so if you
want to disable all the Queen then you
have to hold down some some combination
of keys where's my meat I want I want
some beautiful meat I don't want to
steal me either
I'm trying to figure out like the g5
meet let's play this move just for fun
I'll probably just end up meeting the
three bishops oh you want seven bishops
oh you're so so needy I just lost upon
so maximum number of bishops is six
oh okay this probably makes life easier
wait if I play this
that meaning I don't want to like make a
fool of myself and then not win I also
don't want to steal me like if I play
this and queens and that would be
stalemate so let's
okay let's deliver a check and then
[Music]
check what is this where's my mate so we
know White's gonna promote unless white
doesn't promote
how do I do this let's just play this
move
we'll see if white wants to dunder
commence I'm setting up the discovered
check o opponent left the game Oh
maybe opponents up once returned maybe
lost connection or something I wasn't
sure if there is saltiness yeah promotes
tonight promotes that [ __ ] up would be
the the most funny I think maybe
opponent left the game trying to disable
auto queen trying to have a a YouTube
worthy finish this is not stalemate
White has four legal moves
hey King g6 meet Wow that was a nice
nice finish thanks for the game Risa
lion is not expecting the game time like
this after such a serious fight in the
middle game it was really just just one
one careless move I think white was
trying to be safe like hold on to this
pawn but Knights are also important I
think 95 would have been actually a nice
move here like blocking the bishop
insuring that the pawn is also safe
would have allowed Bishop takes b2 but
then the knight can can do things in the
center anyway yeah I'll probably end up
putting this on youtube so people
watching in the future on youtube hope
you made it to this point
hope the bits didn't scare you away stay
tuned for more content I'm trying to put
out a video every day if you subscribe
and like it will motivate me more so
yeah stay tuned